For Turkey, there's dark clouds on the horizon.
In the aftermath of the failed coup, President
Recep Tayyip Erdogan has launched a crackdown
that would make even Vladimir Putin in Russia
blush, rounding up tens of thousands of people.
Not only the alleged perpetrators, but he's
sacked constitutional court judges, dismissed
1,500 university deans, gone after journalists,
and so forth.
In the fight against the Islamic State, this
is going to have reverberations.
Recep Tayyip Erdogan wants the United States
to extradite Fethullah Gulen, an Islamic cleric
based in Pennsylvania who he sees as a rival,
and it seems that Erogan is willing to hold
the U.S. fight against the Islamic State hostage
by, perhaps in the future, denying the U.S.
ability to use the Incirlik air base.
This puts Europe and the United States in
a conundrum.
Because as Turkey's crackdown accelerates,
as Turkey talks about reimposing the death
penalty, the European Union says, "Hey, this
changes the whole EU accession debate.”
And with regard to the United States, on one
hand, we condemn the coup.
But we didn't mean to give an open door for
a crackdown that would purge tens of thousands.
So what do you think Erdogan is going to do
next?
Let us know in the comments, and let us know
any other topics you'd like AEI scholars to
address in 60 seconds.